Batman was always a crazy person and
that Alfred has been dressing up as all
of these bad guys as a way to distract
him and then it goes on his face a
little steam goes out and then he takes
his first breath but rewind that furnace
to his grandson who's watching him
through the force and says don't let
this happen to you this is rogue theory
today we are solving a murder with the
help of Bruce Wayne we have Eric Voss
Tommy Bechtel and Angelica Trey okay
the Batman there's there was a leak that
Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson's the
Batman movie is actually going to be
what I've been pitching for years you
can find me in multiple videos saying
this a detective story it's finally
gonna be the world's greatest detective
solving a mystery specifically a murder
mystery so what I want to know it's
gonna feature the Rose gallery I'm gonna
set up some some points here some things
that we know about it and then I want to
hear the most rogue theories about what
this movies actually gonna be about so
we know it's rubber pants Benson so you
can't change who is playing Batman okay
we do know that it's a younger Batman we
now know it's a detective story and will
feature members of the rogues gallery
all right and it is not gonna be an
origin story even though it's young
Batman so it's like youthful Batman her
ever but it's not your story doesn't
have to be like and then this is why he
decided to become a he's already bad
yeah you're two or you're three exactly
all right
now I want to hear rogue theories what
mysteries he's solving what's this movie
about anyone desert my rogue theory for
this is okay so when they said younger
like in a cast Robert Pattinson in this
role I've been watching a ton of mind
hunter on Netflix I love this series and
I love Silence of the Lambs I watched
him at the same time they both kind of
have the same thing of a younger but not
like brand-new but just kind of a
younger FBI agent who has to interrogate
and get inside the mind of already
incarcerated
mastermind villains serial killers to
understand a current crime spree that's
happening that they can't they can't
make heads or tails of so what imagine a
scenario where you see a young younger
Batman going back to the Batcave to a
supercomputer listening to old tapes of
Harvey Dent of whatever the Joker is of
the Riddler as they're sitting there
smoking and he's just taken off his cowl
and he's like I can't figure this out
and suddenly they say something that
inspires him he screams that Alfred
Alfred drops his silver platter dress in
the batwing
of some random narrows apartment and
he's able to figure out based off of
something that Harvey Dent and that the
Riddler said he's able to
cross-reference it and figure out using
old-school
FBI crime interrogation tactics with
serial killers
I like 98 percent of this I don't like
that he doesn't go to Arkham Asylum and
actually interview them on the other
statements as he's gone cell by cell
down Arkham Asylum and then maybe
something happens just like in Silence
of the Lambs where Hannibal Lecter
breaks out this leads to all of these
criminal masterminds breaking out of
Arkham Asylum and spreading around
Gotham to set us up with a new rogues
gallery a new cinematic universe of
Batman villains I see what you did there
like you you definitely did slow it down
it does feel a lot more like a mystery
you know going through this and solving
the puzzle and I think that'd be great
to sort of work through that you know
with Robert pets why is that a joke I
don't know I still think of Twilight
when you're thinking about baseball I
recently went factory watch that scene
and just cringed but also was just so I
don't know amazed that that made it to
theaters anyways it's music music area -
so I'm seeing I'm seeing what you did
there but I could also see that being a
little too slow-paced like where's the
action here he's just sitting in the
Batcave when he drops the silver platter
okay everyone
takes all the bathtub yeah I think
though you you would have to go that
route of like he's making visit regular
visits to Arkham and then you know we we
learned about these maybe there's even
like flashbacks or something I remember
he's the one that put these people in
Arkham and so we have like a little bit
of these little mini vignettes yes
imagine the structure of the movie
inside man that spike Lee movie where it
cuts back and forth between the
interviews of the people who are
hostages to the action as it's happening
so we we cut back to Robert Pattinson
interviewing you know Catwoman or
something and and then it cuts back to
this killer on the loose and he's trying
to chase them down I never saw the end
of that movie this is you're starting to
say this quickly as I can't I got like
the flu that night while I was watching
it I was so it's movie the Inside Man I
was feeling so bad in the theaters and I
was like I wish this movie to end I wish
it would end and then the celluloid
melted yeah that only happens in movies
[Laughter]
thank you so much I'm feeling pretty
good about about this this theory though
because what I do like about it is that
it really focuses on getting into their
minds yeah that's something that
actually doesn't happen enough in Batman
stories is you know everyone thought it
talks about the mind of the Joker but
they're all maniacs all of them
including Batman they're a bit of an
extreme yeah then let's see someone
who's in the middle the psychological
profiling of it too
yeah yeah and I could see some really
good villain cameos with it and we
rarely ever get to focus on the actual
like the cleverness or the intelligence
of Batman ever pace to not just have
like the only proof of his detective
work a messy Batcave like for file
folders like pinned to the wall yeah
they flash and show that real quick then
he goes back to just I want to carry
from home
and he's like hasn't taken his meds and
he's got I get that stack of Case Files
away from a dripping stalagtite yes the
cave is no place to do boy USB Drive
we'll just fall apart in that
environment Tommy Tolle's will your road
okay so first of all I really liked your
theory I want you to know that I'm in
support of it but it's a dark it's a
certainly dark and - is dark but mine is
going even - my goal of mine is scary I
want mine to be a you know that's where
these movies are going these days we
have new mutants coming out which is
basically a horror movie with uh is it
ever coming out push back so many times
I mean is it Arya Stark looks like 11 in
it right I wonder if they like overdid
it and they're like this is too scary
it's just Buki and Tommy Bechtold won't
like it so we've got anyway so my my
rogue theory is this is a this is a like
serial killer freaky
7 David Fincher level like creepy Gore
like you know murder so back when you
said his was too dark this is dark but
it's like gory and freaky enough for me
I want to go all the way so there's so
it starts with like there's
disappearances going on in Gotham and
the only thing they're recovering are
parts of the people who disappeared so
we're giving a hand an ear a baseball
cap with so Batman we know he's obsessed
with closure because his parents were
murdered that's the closure he can never
seem to get so these loose ends
literally loose ends of people are
driving him insane so he has to go after
the most sadistic of of Gotham's rogues
your your toymaker
your Jervis Tetch
Mad Hatter these are the characters in
the comic books and in our in our Batman
Canon that actually murder people you
know the more whimsical penguin and
Riddler is tend to just kidnap people
but if you figure out how to stop them
they're like go on it with the rest of
your day and even like I think you can
even start to hint at elements of a new
Joker in this movie like maybe he
suspects the Joker or maybe there's like
the influence of that and finally he
settles on the dollmaker who in the
comics is a is a is it used to be a
physician who did a lot of surgeries and
then became disgraced and had to like
you know go into hiding or whatever his
last name was dual mocker which is
always kind of funny it's very like so I
think you can do that and I think the
thing with these characters are they
haven't been established on screen yet
in movies or in TV so like you can kind
of play around with their origins and
who they are then there's not like a
sacred like oh they have to be done this
way so I think it kind of he's trying to
solve this mystery and check off all of
these boxes of like who would be evil
enough to do this so he goes through and
then I think the thing that you have to
do because the dollmaker isn't an iconic
Batman villain is it's a misdirect like
he he finally settles in and becomes
obsessed with pinning it on the
dollmaker because you know again he
wants the closure and then we need to
find like a there's be a twist at the
end like it needs to be like that like
the doll makers in my vision is an older
like in his 70s and maybe he has like a
traveling Health Service nurse that
comes in and maybe she's convincing him
to like cut these people apart yeah and
then at the end the reveal is that these
people are not dead they've just been
genetically Frankenstein's I'm kind of
into something there at the end yeah
definitely in my head sort of just
become the human centipede essentially
what you was my doctor for a while so
you're saying that the dollmaker is
actually a puppet the dough maker is an
awful puppy yeah they're like maybe he
has a son who is a seemingly failure to
launch like a guy who like lives with
his father and it's like in his 40s but
maybe it's because the Sun is actually
an even
or sick version of the dog I like that
quick reminder that these movies have to
specifically speak to and freak out
Tommy Bechtold and the son that is a
failure to live just you know his
parents aren't don't know if he's gonna
make it yeah is that the part that's
really great grabbing you
I actually thought we'd maybe name the
character Tommy in this version it would
just be kind of a facsimile of me how
much of this have you already enacted
I've got 200 pages written we actually
rolled so Tommy so far none but I'm
ready I mean I'm excited about the part
you planted to it as a puppet show like
Children's Theater at the end if you're
not doing art for everyone what's the
point of even doing it covered with felt
I'm getting ready and prepared I feel
like my paint is a psychopath yeah I'm
gonna go back to the theory that I like
it
the thing that I think it needs is maybe
like like a race against time or
something like as he's doing it it's a
finger that clearly belongs to Robin or
something right yeah Alfred drop the
silver tray because you have no fingers
but definitely like there's there he's
hoping that maybe these people are still
alive it's like the Lindbergh baby but
there's kind of Batman's obsessiveness
as a detective is like he's always kind
of in a race against himself to like get
things done before because in his mind I
feel like his character is inherently
blames himself for everything so like
that's why he has this like Savior
complex and like you know dresses up in
a costume does he receive the body parts
they say it is Robin or something like
at Wayne Manor or something very creepy
because that would mean that the nose I
think they put the severed hand on a
spotlight and project it onto them
[Music]
dealing with a real freak all right and
you call this theory ripping it with
Batman
yeah gotcha so Jack the Ripper but as
Dominic ripped rip he's always ripped
yeah yeah great shred yeah that also
works Angelica
defeat their rogue theories with yours
okay well here's what I was thinking is
maybe separating a little bit away from
the gruesomeness but still keeping you
ignore right but make it more
mind-bending you know more like Robert
Pattinson as you know Bruce Wayne here
he's like questioning himself and he
doesn't know what's reality and what's
like fiction what's an illusion here and
he's I'm thinking maybe like a memento
route or like a dark City where it's
just like there's like false like
unreliable information and he's trying
to gather information and maybe like
catchy like a major villain here and
he's not sure like maybe towards the end
is it me you know having false memories
like he's waking up maybe in certain
places I I'm trying to hash this out but
it's just as like it's it's hard right
well I'm asking but I don't know if I'm
getting ahead of you okay what's causing
all his his confusion well I was
thinking maybe is so we've seen in the
past like scarecrow yeah like
hallucinations like experimental drugs
and things like that but yeah I'm so I'm
fully working it out in my head but I
think that's a really good route to go
yeah and just have it be like we're
constantly we're on edge trying to
figure out like what is real so yeah so
so trying to solve crimes that may or
may not be happening right and that you
may or may not have been the person that
committed them just implications
everywhere and then you know obviously
all the you know we're gonna have some
villains coming in like penguin Catwoman
and it's gonna just mix it all up and
make it super grey area there's a crazy
one-off Batman comic that is kind of
it's it's not quite as I think like
compelling as your idea but it's it's
that that Batman was always a crazy
person and that Alfred has been dressing
up as all of these bad guys as a way to
distract him
he's a rich kid whose parents died in
like in he's like just insane so bet so
elfrid just takes him along on these
adventures beautiful poisoning does it
feature Bruce Wayne going through like
the you brought up like I feel like one
of the cooler things in Nolan's Batman
Begins is this whole thing of like
scarecrows loosen Asians and like we see
these point of view shots where like
Batman's faces is crazy
demonic inky face you see like bats
flying out of scarecrows masks and no
one totally shied away from those kind
of subjective shots because he's such
such an objective filmmaker and I wish
that like he leaned more into that and
Batman Begins it's showing it's kind of
like trippy visuals and I would love to
see a Batman that dives more into that
kind of who was notorious Peschel II
since no are you know as a genre it's so
gritty and kind of like Oh realistic but
the art style and the heavy shadows and
things but then you can really mix that
in with questioning that reality and and
bending it and so I'm gonna give you one
addition on yours too but but anyway you
guys can help me fill in the blank to
start this all off we didn't really
clarify what crime he's trying to solve
so who's been killed Robin great Robin
or someone close to him Gordon Selina
Kyle or Alfred yeah I feel Robin also is
probably like the the one that you like
don't want it to be but the reason why
it can I was gonna say it can be any of
the names you say is because also they
might not be dead right it might be
again he like maybe he sees them at one
point like he's like wait I'm solving
here you're murder you know like he like
if he is losing it it can be you know
yes they're like vertigo a little bit
where he think he's there's like doubles
of people and he thinks he sees the
person he's chasing but it's not that
person that is kind of like that
Hitchcock influence that the director is
mentioning right cuz that would be it'd
be really fun right so rot Robin may or
may not be dead and then Batman is
solving the crime and finding that he
himself may or may not have killed mm-hm
we're just Robin told Alfred like I
don't want to talk to Bruce right now so
you could dress up as someone who
murdered me but if we can just go down
the line again just before we we'd it's
Clair who just had the most rope theory
here just sum it up and maybe in a
tweets worth sure so okay so my version
of the Matt Reeves Robert Pattinson
Batman mine hunter Arkham Asylum
Batman collides with Jack the Ripper and
a thrilling new mystery who will have
the final say who will have the final
slice Batman ripped theatres November
24th take a day Batman like Batman in
like a mind-bending whodunit and could
Batman be the potential villain here
with for this segment
the rogue award is going to it's your
theory is so out there Angelica but I
think by the end you didn't like it so
Tommy so it's just a segment you can you
can get a rogue girl in the next one but
before we go into our next segment real
quick we gotta say some thank yous you
spend one third of your life asleep so
you should be comfortable Casper
mattresses can help
Astra's products are designed to mimic
human curves providing supportive
comfort for all kinds of bodies the
original Casper mattress combines
multiple supportive memory foams for a
quality sleep surface with the right
amount of sink and bounce breathable
design also helps you sleep cool and
regulates your body temperature
throughout the night the mattress is
delivered right to your door in a
surprisingly small box you'll be a
little freaked out at how small of a box
a full-size super comfortable mattress
can be shipped in I actually
legitimately got one of these for my mom
and she says it's her favorite mattress
she's ever had in her entire life by the
way you can be sure of your purchase
with Casper's 100 night risk-free sleep
on it trial and you could get $100
towards select mattresses by visiting
Casper comm slash rock stars and using
rock stars at checkout and of course
terms and conditions apply that's Casper
comm slash rock stars and promo code
rock stars for $100 towards select
mattresses all right back to it guys
Disney cancelled a panel that was going
to feature Hayden Christensen and Ian
McDermott which I think they say they
McDiarmid dharma dylan mcdermott young
anakin skywalker were both gonna be on a
panel and then it got cancelled
for some reason and I mean it could be
as simple as not a great panel
but apparently Disney had some reason to
cancel it so people are thinking oh it's
because it would have given away
something about how Hayden Christensen
could maybe be appearing in Rises
Skywalker of course I mean this has got
to be a smoking gun right good any
cancellation or evidence of a cover-up
means there is a conspiracy at work
we've learned this as fans this is the
only evidence we have so there's no
react assuming that JJ Abrams has
something to hide and we all know he's a
human mystery box one uh then what is he
hiding about maybe bringing Hayden
Christensen back as Anakin Skywalker I
love to the new film why would he bring
him back
okay I remember reading about there was
a leaked scene description where kylo
Ren was going to witness the origin
moment of Darth Vader when the mask gets
lowered on Hayden Christensen's burned
face what if they're gonna reshoot that
scene but his grandfather Anakin
Skywalker who has now become Darth Vader
turns to him and gives him some kind of
frightening warning he thinks he's seen
something that's already historical but
now history speaking to him can you just
- just to clarify and it started a
podcast listeners can you visually walk
us through exactly how this is playing
out you can take the mic with you okay
so imagine we've got plenty of room here
right I don't know the structural
integrity of this table I know my weight
I know not but there is a there's that
moment where Anakin here hold him hold
my beer Anakin is laying on the table
and he's burning he's all burnt and
charred Tommy you can be yeah your droid
you're the medical droid you can be kind
of screaming and then it goes on his
face a little steam goes out and then he
takes his first breath but rewind that
to his grandson who's watching him
through the force and says don't let
this happen to you this is your mind on
that dark side and then kylo wakes up in
a cold sweat
definitely shirtless yeah yeah
kylo wakes up in a terrified deep
breathing realizes oh the history that I
knew about my grandfather's not what I
thought it was was not this majestic of
misunderstood villain who was torn down
there was a coronation it wasn't a
coronation it was torture he was forced
to
this and I don't want this to happen to
me yeah so your pitch is that he is
comes back he's put in this film in
order to set kylo Ren on the good path
yeah yeah gotcha and he just waited
until you know Kyle odd killed enough
people yeah to intervene but he's buried
on Endor that's where they had the
funeral pyre
maybe they revisit his grave or that
site and then that kind of memory is now
reach record in Kyllo and the whole
point of it is to change the memory of
him and take one of the cooler moments
from Revenge of the Sith without which I
think is unfairly maligned from the
original trilogy it's definitely better
than the other two and take one of these
better moments right before though but
right when he because it takes that
first breath as Vader and make it mean
something into these three new films yep
I like that yeah I remember that I see
it yeah cuz we have no just nothing in
sight right now for how kylo is I don't
know he just seems so so on the dark
side like so determined for it when he's
so wrong about Vader where he's like
I'll finish what you started and it's
like he didn't see the last movie he
needs that full wake-up call and and
literally with your theory would you
like to save 10% on your insurance
that's very good yeah we have some
vitamins the Tommy way why are they
bringing back gating it's so funny that
Eric you focus so much on on kylo Ren
because I think this is a Rey play all
day everybody I think that Rey play
Beibei and we do it every day the true
Baxter way yeah I think I think we saw
the spooky sorry Joe is that you hate
Tommy he's gonna cry no this is his rage
spill tea good good
we show her but they will be here later
so anyway this is a replay all day baby
the true gangster way and so we've seen
from like their you know the few things
that have come out that Rey is gonna
have this crazy you know kind of stapler
style lights and then she's got scary
face c-3po has scary eyes I think this
is all gonna be about Rey getting
seduced by little evil Sith Horcruxes
throughout the throughout Endor it and
maybe the wreckage of the Death Star
she's going to have a vision of Hayden
Christensen maybe maybe a like kind of a
like a zombified like Vader helmet
cracked a side face of Hayden
Christensen here here's well here's what
I'm trying to do is I want to actually
support it cuz here's what I do like
about the Horcrux idea is that Ray does
have that moment when she grabs Luke's
lightsaber nobody.one and it was she has
a huge vision right like she run ends up
running out of the cabin maz kanata's
castle because of that
well I'm thinking so Kent Kent the equal
and opposite isn't that what the for so
this is the every action has an equal
and opposite reaction like can't she
have a profound dark vision that way you
know like that was seemingly like
obi-wan and other Jedi's compelling her
to start her quest Kent her her
seduction into the dark side be
compelled in a similar way
maybe that lightsaber has some maybe
that whoever the owner of that dual
bladed lightsaber is is the true
mastermind of all this he or her could
be orchestrating all of this as a giant
puppet master who is it the end of the
day you know for me it's uh it's always
Chewbacca I think maybe what will bum me
out about your thing is that poor Hayden
Christensen like gets pulled out of
forced retirement to be a dead face in a
mask
I don't scare you
to meet you
if you don't want this to happen I will
call JJ Abrams's tonight and cancel us
going forward with this drive anymore I
drove my car to JJ Abrams house too many
times just battering ramming my way in
and finally I found out he didn't live
there now here nah
so Hayden Christensen's purpose is to I
think he's in the moment I'm agreeing
with this theory that movie I think he
appears in a spooky imagery that's part
of the seduction I'm trying to get ready
to the dark side
gotcha that's great he's a conduit to
that all right I like it okay well I was
thinking a little bit on maybe like a
simpler less you know mind crazy
mind-bending but I was thinking maybe
like he's a clone I do like that because
that means that we could just have Darth
Vader back in in this movie and i think
i think clones are gonna play a role I
went into it before
Rey clone uses propaganda to to like
reinvigorate you know like yeah yeah
exactly I feel like that's the big tie
they kind of make that so so what
happens he shows up as a clone and
what's your theory I'm thinking maybe he
shows up as a clone and he could
possibly you know being in talks with
kylo and maybe like I guess kylo
I think he needs a little bit of
guidance obviously so maybe he could be
sort of like guiding here
I mean kylo is obsessed with him he
takes a real Instagram post seeking that
father figure
you know that's wholly interesting it's
the character that that kylo is the most
driven by could just show up and then
they have to like defeat him or
something or or fight him he's also just
remind you that character even though we
kind of over like all past Anakin sky
Walker that's because the prequels
didn't stick with us enough but the
character of Anakin Skywalker is be like
biggest deal in in the Star Wars
universe he is the Immaculate Conception
that the force made supposedly she
claims she has a claim yeah but if what
she says is true this is the force baby
I mean it's kind of it's a big deal if
we're gonna wrap up this entire saga
he's the mascot bring him back so your
thing has him playing the biggest role
right maybe he's even the one pulling
strings or yeah everybody he's been a
clone yeah and and honestly it could be
one of those situations where it does
take a turn and he's actually being
puppeteered in some way shape or form
you know by of course the the great
mastermind of this whole this whole
thing but yeah I could definitely see
maybe him yeah being cloned and then
being used as like not like propaganda
but definitely being a tool being a
puppet hmm all right give him to me
again in a tweet okay can I lay back on
the day yes my tweet is kylo nightmare
sees Hayden they get scared straight
yeah these are bad tweets
what is this tweet me boss just we did
kylo - is written in the form of a
headline it's it's a rapelay
Jedi says later Vader - scary vision Wow
I love it I don't I can't decipher any
of it but I'm not good with those guns a
headline
it's a rapelay Jedi says later Vader -
scary vision okay
later Vader - the scary vision one more
time there is no Dana there is only Zoo
[Laughter]
yeah great clone Vader clone Vader
returns oh yeah clone beta return
give me yours so it's a vision it's a
vision it's a right way I mean it's a
clone it's got to get them some rhyme
theory yeah all right great you guys are
I mean for no reason there are no points
awarded all right so I just catch people
up Tommy has one rogue doll and then
Angelica has the other Road which means
right now can either end this whole show
could end in a tie if Eric is able to
take home the last segment or one of
these two is gonna go home crown Victor
of the episode road questions will
decide it question myself wait I'll buy
my own rogue action figures
like I do no no you don't do that no one
do that you can't these are all marked
in very specific ways you guys could win
on this or be relevant guys it chapter 2
came out last week and who's got the
best creepy kind of Pennywise e laughs e
[Laughter]
Woody Woodpecker will give that point
Eric for trying the most guys it was
good 50 cent said this week that he
direct a Marvel movie by the way just
he's willing to direct a Marvel movie as
long as it didn't take too much of his
time what we call him the psychology
community a loving fence he's putting
boundaries up he wants to do it on his
terms when did you enter the psychology
community what MCU movie would we be
okay
50 cent screwing up hmm Howard the Duck
let's think about this you know there's
a daredevil comic line written by Bob
Gale where daredevil sues himself for
Matt Murdock sues daredevil and it's a
gritty courtroom crime drama I think 50
cent with his work on power really like
you know like a courtroom setting kind
of lower you know it wouldn't be a lot
of action to shoot day so it wouldn't
mess with his busy 50 cent scheduled
days obviously sure movie there's so
much gunfire so and these are all movies
that were okay with him ruining strength
Tommy did have three answers I'm gonna
give it to Tommy answers guys margot
robbie is making a Tank Girl movie
what's the first thing you'd do if you
owned a tank Oh smashed into JJ Abrams
house I would stop Erik from doing that
with my I would definitely want to crush
things yeah I don't know like maybe like
drive over something like is if there's
like a miniature maybe drive through
like a studio and then knock down all
the set stuff who does the studio belong
to is it us and you're gonna do that
thing where you ruin the set of a time
which I think means that Angelika takes
Garden Ramsay or Marie Antoinette there
you go there's your second character
that also have that one wrong it is Anna
Paquin Road
that means that Angelica tre you win
this episode sure where can we find you
Angelica you can find me on most social
media a tray ayy tra e on Twitter as
well there and Instagram Angelica tray
sweet Tommy where can we find you you
can find me on all social platforms at
Tommy Beck told seek me out you just
might like what you find
disgusting son Instagram and Twitter and
this week rock star on the rock stars
will have a video about the watchman is
HBO series what's going on with it
yeah it's a timeline of it why is Robert
Redford president yes in the show it's
awesome and we're gonna look into some
other Marvel theories looking at what
the hell the tin rings has to do with
the future of the MCU and next week
spider-man apart from home comes out on
digital rerelease so we'll be doing some
rewatch is finding all the other Easter
eggs we've missed the first time around
milk yeah i'm elina you can find me at
puma lean on twitter and instagram guys
thank you so much for going rogue with
us you guys to let us know in the
comments down below which of these
theories made any sense and which ones
went really rogue and who deserved to
actually win if you don't agree with me
that's fine I make sure to get the
podcast version of this by going to
rogue theory as a podcast feed comes out
before it does and video also make sure
to follow new rock stars and rock stars
all over the place thank you so much I
love everyone here mostly
[Music]